world premiere of the next major life
estranged game
when i moved to haven springs i hadn't
seen my brother gabe in
years alex
it's just so good to see you again
welcome to haven
this place is pretty sweet
i'm glad you two met is this dude my
best friend and this dude
hands me the best beers alex right
i'm stuff i didn't realize that we all
knew you were coming
for the first time in years well what do
you think
i love it i really let myself believe
welcome home i don't know what to
believe now
except gabe is dead
this one's for you gabe
[Music]
hearing everyone talk about my brother
about the life he had here with all of
you
i lost the chance to have that
what happened to gabe was a senseless
tragic accident
it wasn't an accident son now is not the
time
alex are you okay
no they're definitely hiding something
what happened here haven't's a community
we help each other
alex be careful there's something
you should know about me
[Music]
i know what other people are feeling i
can see these
auras around them
if they're angry or sad or afraid i feel
it too
when i focus i can even understand why
they're feeling it
and if somebody's feeling something big
it infects me
and i lose control
i've never told anyone
but now i can find out what's really
going on you'll need help
i've got your back
[Music]
welcome to the world premiere of the
next major game in the life is strange
series
developed by deck 9 games i'm maya also
known as mxm tune
and i'm a musician and a huge life
estranged fan so i'm super excited to be
your host for today's show
if you're not familiar with the games
like the strange is a series of
stand-alone adventures that explore
dramatic emotional stories about regular
people
but with a stunning twist of the
supernatural
life is strange true colors features a
brand new cast
power and story so it's the perfect
place to jump in
if you're new to the series now let's
throw the spotlight over to deck 9 games
director
zach garris and eric amore the actor
behind our brand new lead
alex chen for more life is strange true
colors is the game we at deck 9 have
been working on since 2017.
it has been a real labor of love for us
we are so delighted to share it with you
today
at its heart this is a game about
empathy about how we connect to each
other
the story is driven by a complex mystery
with supernatural elements
all brought to life by an incredible
cast led by our new player character
alex
played by erica mori what i love most
about alex is she's this smart
resilient young woman who at the start
of the game has already weathered a
really difficult life in the foster care
system
but she still has this hope for the
future that
somewhere she can find a place to call
home
at the invitation of her brother alex
travels to the town of haven springs
it's a fresh start framed against the
beautiful mountain vistas
sprawling lakes and colorful
architecture
a setting that embodies the promise of
every small town across america
it's her chance to start over in a place
where she can rebuild her relationship
with gabe
after eight years apart
alex
oh what's the protocol for reuniting
with your long-lost sister after eight
years
in life estranged true colors alex's
power
or curse as she calls it at the start of
the game
is an unparalleled empathic ability the
psychic power
of empathy it allows her to experience
the emotions of other characters around
her
but it's also a volatile power that can
bleed into
and take over her own emotions if she's
not careful
this power is a key part of the game and
very much
under your control and there are plenty
of opportunities to use your power as
you freely explore the streets and
spaces of haven springs
on her very first day in haven springs
alex meets our cast
including two new friends and potential
romantic interests
ryan and steph who fans may recognize
from life is strange before the storm
our extensive cast of characters is at
the heart of every moment of the game
and for the first time they're rendered
using full performance capture
technology
captured and animated here in-house at
deck 9.
making this the most visually advanced
entry in the series
and the true next generation of life is
strange
in life estranged true colors the
mystery surrounding gabe's death is what
ties everything together
after alex's brother dies in what
appears to be an accident
alex quickly realizes there's a larger
story behind what happened to him
and she's determined to get to the truth
it becomes clear that only alex
using her psychic power of empathy can
uncover
what really happened we can't wait for
you to experience alex's journey
this is your chance to build your own
future for her
and for the entire town of haven springs
[Music]
thanks guys and there's one more thing
i'm excited to reveal that i'm providing
alex chen's in-game singing voice
as a long-time fan of life is strange
being even a small part of this
universe and of alex means the absolute
world to me
here's a short clip of alex feeling
uncertain after having a rocky start to
her first day
in hayden springs
when you were here before
i couldn't look you in the eye
[Music]
you'd dress like an angel
your skin makes me cry
you float like a feather
in a beautiful world
i wish i was special
[Music]
you're so very special
but i'm a creepy
i'm who you know
what the hell am i doing here
[Music]
i don't belong here
i am so excited for this game and i hope
that you're feeling the exact same way
after this first look
and now the big news that you've been
waiting for
we're absolutely thrilled to announce
that the full game is coming out in
september
that's right the full game you won't
have to wait for the rest of the story
you can binge it all at once or use the
chapter breaks to take a much needed
emotional breather
you can pre-order life estranged true
colors right now on lifeistrange.com
there's also one more very
special thing we've yet to reveal
we're delighted to announce that life is
strange
and life is strange before the storm
return in an all-new
remastered collection featuring enhanced
visuals and animations
[Music]
two
[Music]
the life is strange remastered
collection will be available as a part
of the life is strange true colors
ultimate edition
and also available standalone later on
this year
and that's it for today thank you so
much for watching
and make sure to keep an eye on the life
is strange channels for more
[Music]
you